welcome to another episode of the
stronger bioscience podcast in this
week's episode Greg and I shared the
feats of strength duties and then we
take a deep dive into some research on
how sleep affects performance and body
composition we also have an interview
with dr. Brandon Roberts who tells us
about his current bodybuilding prep why
some people respond better to training
than others and why sleep is so
important for people who lift as always
thank you for listening and enjoy the
episode welcome back to the stronger by
science podcast this is your host Eric
Trexler I'm joined today by temporary
guest host Greg knuckles thanks for
having me back home you bet so feats of
strength is a fan favorite in terms of
our segments and I am gonna let you take
it but I want to get one in first so
there's a pretty lively debate about
whether bodybuilding is a great sport or
the greatest sport and I would argue
that it is in fact the greatest sport
and what that means is that by winning a
pro bodybuilding show that's one of the
greatest feats of strength you could
really hope to accomplish despite the
fact that there's no force being
generated but in this case we've got one
of the all-time greats
the first feat of strength this week is
Dexter Jackson so we record this on like
a 45 week time delay this this happened
like approximately a year and a half ago
but no so Dexter Jackson a few weeks ago
won the IFBB Tampa Pro and Dexter
nicknamed the blade is an absolute
legend we've talked about him on the
show before but I'm looking at his
contest history on Wikipedia he had a
top ten Olympia finish in 1999 a top ten
Olympia finish in 1999 when I was eight
years old
yeah think about what you were doing in
1999 and then consider the fact that he
is very much in the running to
potentially win an Olympia in a few
weeks I was prepping for y2k
I think we all were and successfully I
would say I think you you weathered
pretty well yeah we we made it through
but so Dexter Jackson you're incredible
you keep doing it I don't know how he's
49 years old he turns he turns 50 like
three weeks after the Olympia this year
yeah so he's uh it's just incredible I'm
like and he still looks just as good as
ever he looks just the good looks as
good as he looked when he won the
Olympia he he has slightly grayer hair
yeah that's it that uh that TMZ clip of
him you showed me a few months ago is
the best you what do you want to recap
that clip for the listeners yeah so
Dexter Jackson like I don't know him I
don't know anybody that does know him
but he seems very chill and pretty cool
and so like TMZ they kind of just like
swarm famous people and like put a mic
in their face and ask them questions
and Dexter's like in his car leaving the
gym or something like Dexter and they
start asking these questions he just
being like chill like you can tell he
kind of wants to go but he's being nice
and then they're like Dexter how'd you
get so big and he kind of like pauses to
think of like yeah you can see the
wheels turning like do I admit to a
federal felony or like how can I answer
this question he's like thinking about
how honest he wishes to be and he just
kind of smiles it says like genetics bro
I think that's what he said right yeah
there's something like that but he just
drives away but in any case like if
Dexter Jackson wins the Olympia I'm
going to be so stoked it'd be so cool
yeah I mean so god I'm so bad with names
who's the guy who got like great body
builder from the 90s and got like a
special invite to be in the Olympia last
year Kevin Love Roni
yeah yeah like looked great leading up
to it but then when he stepped onstage
you realized why he had only been
sharing pictures of his upper body right
yeah thing is like dude everyone was
freaking out because they're like man
Kevin lavro he looks so good for his age
if memory serves I think he
like 54 so he's not that much older than
Dexter Jackson but like Dexter Jackson
still legitimately has a Olympia level
physique yeah love lavro knees current
age he turned 55 like two months ago
yeah so I mean when you yeah when you
look at other people who were pro
bodybuilders that are like three years
older than Dexter yeah you look at them
and that you're like they haven't been
in competitive shape in 11 years correct
but like Dexter is just winning Pro Show
still it's it's crazy it's nasty all
right you can take it from here yeah so
my first feat of strength more of a feat
of power and integrated Impulse Simone
biles so I don't know who both listens
to this and follows gymnastics but if
you don't you should because gymnasts
are so freakishly athletic that I feel
so I feel like gymnastics is a natural
sport for power lifters to also be into
because powerlifting is essentially just
a sport of like raw expression of a
single physical characteristic that
beans strength and so it's just you know
freaky athleticism not all that much
like strategy goes into it but it's just
you know what can you do to a bar and I
feel like especially especially floor
exercise in gymnastics is kind of
similar because like they get points for
the little dance bits they get between
tumbling passes but ultimately it's just
a question of like how much goddamn
power can you put through the floor to
vault yourself 15 feet in the air to do
crazy [ __ ] and Simone biles pulled off
the first successful triple-double at
gymnastics nationals either last week or
two weeks ago which is two backflips
along with three complete rotations in
the air which like if you've never seen
gymnastics the floor that they do floor
exercise on is like extra springy so
it's not just doing it you know off of
concrete
but even that being the case one being
able to launch herself that high in the
air to pull that off is nasty and then
just being able to know where you are in
space to be able to land it it's
absolutely absurd so if you haven't seen
that you should check it out it's one of
the most impressive singular feats of
athleticism that I have ever seen do you
remember we were probably kids when this
happened wasn't it Tony Hawk trying to
do the first 900 that they like made a
huge deal of it and it was like oh yeah
stadium lights and televised and all
that yeah that was crazy man this is
this I get gave me like the same feeling
to watch her rotate that many times I
remember when Tony Hawk did it back when
like everybody played Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater - back when it was good back when
it was awesome but but no it's it's just
crazy to watch somebody pull something
off like that so if you're also into
just rotating things and Tony Hawk Tony
Hawk maybe two or three years ago he put
out a video where he was trying to see
if he could still put down a nine
hundred at I believe 48 years old and he
failed like 50 times in a row or
something but he eventually put one down
like as of a couple years ago the Duke
could still do a 900 which I want to say
to this day maybe only like five people
have so I mean Tony Hawk retired from
Bert just to give everyone else a shot
like dude dude would probably still be
in in the running for a bronze medal if
if he wanted to enter vert at the X
Games at 51 years old well if he was
Dexter Jackson he would just approaching
his prime yes you can look at this one
of two ways either Tony Hawk is the
Dexter Jackson of skateboarding or
Dexter Jackson is the Tony Hawk of
bodybuilding both sound good to me sure
weren't we going to discuss what sports
Simone biles should actually be
competing in yeah I mean so we had
talked about this previously and I think
it's a shame that she's wasting her
talents on gymnastics when she I if you
watch her floor routine it's very clear
she should she could be a
top level figure competitor and so to
see her spinning our wheels following
this gymnastics tough stuff is kind of
ashamed and I hope she'll come to her
senses and make the transition see I
disagree she also appears to have quite
long arms combined with the fact that
she's like three foot ten so I look at
her and I think world class sumo
deadlift her she may have she may be the
first person to acquire the legendary
two inch range of motion and I mean if
she can apply enough force to do a
triple double one has to assume that she
can deadlift at least five six hundred
pounds if she applied herself to it and
she is like a ball of muscle yeah but
here's the thing when it comes to sports
selection you have to consider what
you're what you're likely to be good at
but also what does the most good for
society powerless and that would be
figure it's happening it's absolutely
powerlifting no I mean America we get
our identity from our top level figure
competitor is like that's how we know
absolutely ya know when people are
sitting around a fourth of July barbecue
and they're talking about America's
great national treasures and national
heroes you know people are gonna bring
up names like Blaine Sumner and John
hack reminisce about the days of Ed Cohn
and Captain Kirk that that is where
America derives its sense of place in
the world no you're wrong cuz they they
put the 4th of July
right when Olympia preps or started so
that you can that's why they put it it's
also around the time i PF world preps
are starting mm-hmm USA PL nationals
that's the one in october yeah well I
mean well sort it out later
sure all right who else did strong
things okay so onto to actual
traditional feats of strength
natan the cool became the first teenager
to total 2100 in competition last week
so there was there are previously been
two people total two thousand as
teenagers maybe three
dangit what's his name
blanking on the name the really they
were both Texans mark repeat oh no no no
but that does jog my memory one of them
was Mark Henry legendary power lifter
switched over to weightlifting very good
at that as well he was the first person
to total 2,000 as a teenager I forget
the most recent guy's name but but
talking about selecting sports so in
Texas like powerlifting is an offseason
sport that a lot of the football players
to do to get stronger for football
during the offseason and I forget the
guys name but another Texas high school
or total 2000 as as an 18 year old and
so many people were like oh my god he's
gonna be a perennial IPF champion and
he's like no psyche I'm going to play
football at Baylor and try to make it to
the NFL and they were there were a bunch
of people on reddit being like god this
guy's wasting his talents I was like
come on man but they meant it not like
us I think a couple of them were
actually sincere it's like ah man just
imagine how good he could have been and
he's like yeah and he's probably
imagining like his rookie contract where
he's gonna make at least like 5 million
dollars if he makes the NFL but yeah so
yeah Nate McCool 2100 total at 19 years
old
absolutely insane similarly insane is
Erik Lewis total 2300 at 20 years old
which is absolutely absurd so that is
not that many humans of total 2300 so
the fact that he's doing it at 23 years
old is incredibly impressive
and he's also seemingly progressing at a
pretty quick rate he just totaled his
first 2200 in March of this year so how
old is he again 20 years old 20 years
old
so yeah I mean still young
still improving very
quickly I mean anyone touching 2,400 is
among the best like three or four guys
in the world and so he's still super
young and coming hard at that so that's
also just unbelievably impressive the
feat of strength recently that I think
probably got the most press is that John
hack recently totaled nine hundred seven
and a half kilos or just north of two
thousand pounds at one eighty one which
again is absurd I remember when Jesse
Norris did that back in the day everyone
was freaking out and you know now that's
moved down to the 181 class so at this
rate of progress we're gonna see two
thousand total of 165 in like four years
which will probably just make me jump
off a bridge I don't know why you're
looking at me but so what one thing that
I want to make sure doesn't go
unmentioned here as well is that two
people actually broke the two thousand
pound mark at one eighty one last
weekend
both John hack and Cody blasek did so
hack did it with nice leaves plastic did
it with wraps but both of them broke the
two thousand pound mark obviously hacks
is more impressive because knee wraps do
obviously help you lift more but yeah
both of them broke that milestone I've
seen a bunch of people talking about
hack virtually no when talking about
Cody plastic so props to him as well one
thing I want to just note though about
Jeff about just how stupid stupid
meaning impressive both of those totals
were is that so the the highest total at
181 without wraps that had been done
previously I believe was a Lexington did
825 kilos which is less than that I I
think it's like eighteen hundred and
twenty give or take so
hacks like 200 pounds ahead of his
closest competition in that weight class
without knee traps which is stupid like
he's he's ten percent better than anyone
he's competing against now obviously
like Cody plastic probably doesn't get
two hundred pounds out of his knee traps
so that class as a whole is improving
but like both of those guys are just
eating everyone else for breakfast these
days so circling back to where we
started talking about Dexter Jackson
still awesome aging like a fine wine
someone else who is doing that is David
Rick's who recently turned 60 years old
and squatted a shade over 600 for a set
of five as like his 60th birthday
present to himself which is ridiculous
that's a very normal way for one to
celebrate one sixtieth birthday and if
you don't know who David Rick's is like
one you should the dudes a legend but
two he's not a huge guy either he
competes in the the 1993 kilo class so
we're not talking like a super
heavyweight squatting 600 for a set of
five for their 60th birthday like normal
size dude which again ridiculously
impressive okay so down to our last
three recent feats of strength
Kevin okole more commonly known as Kevin
oak recently broke both the squat record
and the total record in the 242 class
without knee wraps untested so the squat
breaks Amit's appears record in that
weight class and the total record breaks
Larry Weil TSA's record so he squatted
380 kilos which is 837 pounds and
totaled nine 87.5 kilos which is 20 177
pounds again both world records crazy
impressive I am personally probably the
most excited there that he broke the
squat record because so to squat records
ago in that weight class was captain
kirk kirk are w'iskey squatted 375 kilos
which you know captain kirk was a a
consummate squatter his squats were
always fantastic then that record got
broken in maybe like 2014 or so by
Amit's appear who to his credit is a
very very strong guy held the world
record for the squat and for weight
classes simultaneously from 181 all the
way up to 242 which is impressive but
what was maybe a little bit less
impressive was his squat depth for most
of those records so oak squat had very
unquestionable depth so it's it's good
to see that record become more
legitimate again next feat of strength
ryu kee Fujimoto 19 year old bender from
japan benched 260 kilos recently that's
573 pounds he is I'm pretty sure an IPF
competitor which you don't see that many
benches in the IPF sniffing at 600 so
that's one super impressive just the
sheer weight to the fact that he's only
19 years old and 3 it seems like he may
be transitioning from equipped bench but
this kid's just an absolute phenom when
it comes to the bench press
I think the first exposure people had to
him is back in 2016 when he was 16 years
old a video of him surfaced doing a gym
lift in a single plied bench shirt at
405 kilos which is eight hundred and
ninety pounds which I don't think he's
ever done that much in competition but
like I mean he he did it there was video
of it so it's it's been clear for a
while that this kid's just an absolute
phenom on the bench press and he looks
like he's very very quickly approaching
that 600 pound mark again I'm pretty
sure in in the IPF which would be wild
and then last as another training lift
Blaine Sumner Blaine super cool big fan
of the guy everyone knows that he's the
current best in the world in single ply
in the IPF but what people seem to
forget is he used to also be absolutely
incredible raw he is still an incredibly
good raw lifter
he just doesn't compete raw anymore he
recently posted a gym lift of him
squatting four hundred and fifty five
kilos which is a thousand and three
pounds basically looks like a speed rep
which his best raw squatting competition
back in the day was four hundred and
fifteen kilos which is nine hundred and
fourteen pounds so I mean he's he's
looking like he could show up to a raw
meat and still take out anyone in the
world except for Ray Williams like he's
so strong and as someone else who like I
squat similarly to him obviously way
less weight but just our bodies force us
to do like a very hip dominant squat
without much forward knee travel so it's
it's good to see someone with that squat
style succeeding Blaine also super cool
guy really good dude so glad to see that
his trainings going well and that he is
looking stronger than ever a lot of
people did very strong things the last
few weeks they did it's awesome
all right so for the next segment we've
got research review which is kind of a
more nuanced detailed look at some
research papers that caught our interest
lately and Greg's got a couple papers
that he wants to talk about yeah so the
first one I thought was interesting and
I feel like I'm probably gonna get a
fair amount of [ __ ] for talking about it
but that's fine whatever
come at me haters I'll just tell
everyone that your pain is four hundred
ninety nine dollars a month for our beef
service I was gonna say I did talk to
our lawyers about that and they said
based on the way we advertise it that
actually could be like if people are
just mean to us that might qualify as
rendering services yeah I mean that's
what I was thinking so we closed our
billable instances of interaction
anytime someone talked [ __ ] I'm just
gonna send them an invoice yeah and it
is retroactive as well so if you have
been mean to Greg on the Internet in the
last seven to ten years you might be
receiving an invoice and you can just
make that payable through PayPal that
works but yeah so I feel like this one's
going to be somewhat controversial but I
think it's neat so there's a paper title
was Effects of upper body lower body or
combined resistance training on the
ratio of follow statin and myostatin in
middle-aged men
so just for some background myostatin I
think most people are aware is a hormone
that essentially limits hypertrophy it
seems to primarily have its effects on
satellite cells and my nuclei such that
in myostatin knockout animals they
develop just an absolutely tremendous
amount of muscle tissue so if you ever
want to see some really really freaky
looking mice just google myostatin
knockout mice if you want to see the
effects in dogs google whippet versus
bully with it it's the same breed of dog
but they have a reasonably high
occurrence of a recessive trait that
gives them myostatin knock out the bully
whippets are super super jacked or if
you want to go to my facebook profile 3
profile pictures ago I took a picture
with a Belgian blue bowl which is a type
of cow that has been bred to be
myostatin mutant they're not
particularly large I guess I guess I
just assumed that they were bigger like
vertically but like you know I've been
around Black Angus cows Black Angus cows
are much larger than Belgian Blue Bulls
are but just I'm in all of the size of
those lads just the sheer amount of
muscle tissue they have is absolutely
absurd Belgian Blues are the Dexter
Jackson of boys they're they're not the
biggest on stage but they are muscular
as hell and lean yeah they're very
impressive but anyway so that's
myostatin and follow Statten
the kind of a nuanced way to look at it
is it's kind of the reverse myostatin
not exactly but basically myostatin
seems to inhibit hypertrophy endogenous
fala statin seems to promote hypertrophy
a few years back people were promoting
certain supplements as follow statin
boosters they didn't really seem to pan
out very well but endogenous follow
statin does seem to to promote
hypertrophy so anyway you want low
myostatin high follow satin if you want
to get jacked so that was the background
of this study what they did is they took
some middle-aged men they had a control
group who cares and then they had three
I mean come on dude like if one one
thing that irks me a little bit is like
when there are studies that have control
groups when you very much don't need
control groups which is like if if you
have an exercise study where you expect
things to change in untrained people
having a control group just makes
recruitment more of a pain in the ass
without really giving you anything
especially if the outcome is like
strength gains because like we [ __ ]
know that lifting weights makes people
stronger we don't need to recruit twice
as many folks just to verify that not
lifting weights doesn't make people
stronger anyway so there was a control
group who cares about them there were
three training groups one was only doing
upper body training one was only doing
lower body training and one was doing
combined upper and lower body training
and so what they saw in terms of the
Palestine and myostatin is that follow
Staten generally tended to increase in
all three groups with the largest
increase in the group doing combined
upper and lower body training and
myostatin myostatin tended to decrease
in the group only doing lower body
training didn't really seem to change in
the group only doing upper body training
and decreased the most in the group
doing combined upper and lower body
training such that the ratio of follow
Staten increase to myostatin decrease
like the follow Staten demise
and ratio improved the most in the group
doing combined upper and lower body
training still improved in the group
only doing lower body training and then
improved the least in the group only
doing upper body training so from that
one may what one might make the
assumption that doing both upper and
lower body training puts your body
hormonal e in a place that is going to
be more conducive to hypertrophy than
only doing upper body training would be
so that sounds controversial reason it
sounds controversial is that back in the
day people used to put forth like I
remember there were there were like tea
nation articles it's like you won't big
biceps you got to do squats like squats
are the best bicep exercise there are
and a lot of it was based on the now
largely discredited hormone hypothesis
of hypertrophy that when you exercise
you tend to get acute elevations in
testosterone and growth hormone the idea
was those acute elevations in
testosterone and growth hormone promoted
hypertrophy and so if you trained for
larger acute hormonal elevations that
would lead to greater hypertrophy so in
those studies they tended to see much
larger post-exercise increases in
testosterone with lower body training
than upper body training so the idea
being well if you want big arms you got
to make sure you do lower body training
as well get those big post-exercise
testosterone excursions and then if you
also do some curls in that workout also
that that big spike in testosterone is
gonna help you help your arms get big
and I think I think we look back on that
idea and mock it because one that
perspective was massively overstated you
know go to any gym in the world and
there's gonna be guys who are pretty big
that obviously barely trained their legs
and still have jacked upper bodies so
it's not like squatting is the key to
getting big arms like training your arms
is the key to getting big arms and also
I think people come
lelee through that idea under the bus
because it was tied to the hormone
hypothesis centered around testosterone
and growth hormone however when we look
back at the research that has actually
tested that general idea and has
actually measured changes in strength or
muscle size longitudinally we do
actually see that there is some evidence
for that effect occurring so going back
to 2001 there was a paper by Hansen
titled The effect of short-term strength
training on human skeletal muscle : the
importance of physiologically elevated
hormone levels see there's the rub they
tried to tie it to the hormone
excursions which i think is why people
tend to either not talk about this study
now or if they do they tend to talk
about it derisively but basically there
was they used to within subject design
here one group or one arm did curls in
the same workout that they also did like
training the other arm did the same curl
workout but without the light training
in the same training session and what
they saw is that the arm that was
trained in the same session as legs had
larger increases in isometric force
output than the arm that was that just
did the same arm training program
without the additional leg training one
reason that people tend to sometimes
disregard this study is just due to
maybe failure and randomization the
group or the arm that was also doing the
leg training pre training was about 20
to 25 percent weaker than the other arm
was and this tends to be the only study
that people will bring up if they talk
about this concept at all so it did have
some weaknesses specifically the fact
that the arms didn't seem to be they did
they just randomized they didn't
counterbalance so there were some pre
training strength differences and these
researchers did seem to tie it
specifically to the hormone hypothesis
so people tend to not think too much
about this study anymore
more recently in 2011 Randstad and
colleagues had a study called
physiological elevation and
endogenous hormones results in superior
strength training adaptations again not
talking about what the study literally
did but tying it hard to the hormone
hypothesis but it was basically the same
thing unilateral within subject design
one arm just at arm training the other
arm that arm training and the same
workout that they also did leg training
and in that study again I if memory
serves in this study strength gains were
pretty similar but the arm that was
trained along with legs had a larger
increase in arm flexor cross-sectional
area so seeing more hypertrophy there
again most people don't talk about this
this study anymore because people
completely disregard the hormone
hypothesis and this is seen more as a
hormone hypothesis study than just a
training legs and arms together study
then even more recently in 2016 and
finally published in 2018 there was a
study called effective lower body
resistance training on upper body
strength adaptation in trained men by
Bartolome at all and in this study what
they did is they had two different
groups that were both doing a
combination of upper and lower body
training but one of them was doing bench
press training with low volume but
fairly high intensity lower body
training the other one did the same
bench program if memory serves but had a
higher volume lower body training
program as well and in that study the
group doing the higher volume lower body
training along with their bench training
had larger increases in bench press one
rep max
and also a larger increase in arm muscle
area so we see three prior studies we're
doing either lower body training or
higher volume lower body training along
with upper body training either leads to
more strength gains or more hypertrophy
than either not doing lower body
training in tandem or doing lower volume
lower body training and tandem with the
upper body stuff
and I feel like this most recent study
looking at myostatin and fala statin
possibly ties all of this together
so this most recent study was looking at
resting levels of these hormones and one
of the weaknesses of the original
hormone hypothesis was it was just
looking at fluctuations in acute levels
of testosterone and growth hormone you
know elevations that go back to baseline
in like 30 minutes or an hour whereas
like you know we see that large
increases in testosterone from like
injections makes people super jacked
seems to right yeah but you know having
an elevation that only lasts 30 minutes
maybe doesn't do all that much but there
is some prior research looking at
hypertrophic responsiveness that seems
to indicate that people who have the
largest reductions in myostatin as a
result of resistance training are also
the people who have the largest
increases in hypertrophy in response to
resistance training so if we're seeing
that the combination of upper and lower
body training affects myostatin follow
statin levels that could possibly be
something kind of tying all of this
together so again I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent confident in this effect
but I think that people have completely
disregarded the idea of getting more
upper body growth from training and
along with lower body I think people
have completely thrown out that idea and
I'm just kind of arguing that maybe
there's still something more there than
people realize so and again I don't want
to overstate the effect so I'm not
saying you know the key to big arms is
to do curls after squats but I am saying
that you know maybe it is a little
beneficial like maybe you're gonna get a
little larger upper body strength gains
a little more muscle growth if you do
your upper body training in the same
session that you also do some reasonably
high volume lower body stuff yeah one of
the challenges with like trying to be
objective with this evidence-based thing
is like sometimes there are some
findings that you're
I feel like these deserve attention I'm
not sure I can paint the whole picture
yet mm-hmm like I don't know if I can
tell you exactly how and why mm-hmm but
why did we observe it a few times yeah
like we have we have several studies
finding pretty similar results like
there might be something to this yeah I
mean and that's that's how it always
starts is like that's an interesting
thing that we found a few times in a row
mm-hmm and then you you start digging
more yeah and I also think it's I think
this general discussion is well
illustrates the drawbacks of ascribing a
mechanism to something too quickly
because often it's it's not uncommon
that you observe something that's
perfectly legitimate and valid and then
you say we found this due to reasons a B
and C and then subsequent research comes
out that finds that you know reasons a B
and C aren't valid that those aren't
likely plausible mechanisms and then
people kind of throw the baby out with
the bathwater when the fact is you did
make whatever observation it was and
maybe it's just due to some other
mechanism than the mechanisms that
people were looking at previously I
think it's the same thing as like kedo
stuff you know keto intermittent fasting
all of it like you know someone says hey
like I started doing intermittent
fasting and it's been good and the
reason it's good is this jack in my
growth hormone up to know like that's
that's not why it's because you're not
eating for more hours out of the day and
it might be helping you manage your
hunger and therefore eat less or like
with keto like you're removing a lot of
very highly palatable foods from your
diet it's probably not due to the
insulin reduction it's probably just due
to you eating less so you know just
don't I think that mechanisms are
obviously super important from a
scientific scientific perspective but I
don't think practitioners by and large
need to get crazy hung up on mechanisms
I think just
the observation of what actually occurs
is for most people the most important
thing yeah I remember going through a
similar kind of thing with when I first
started looking at the literature with
high doses of caffeine during creatine
loading mm-hmm and I would talk to a lot
of really knowledgeable people about it
and I'm like so I think I found like
three maybe four studies that did a
creatine loading protocol with high-dose
caffeine during it and the the creatine
was not organic in any of those three to
four interventions and they're like yeah
but the mechanism just doesn't make
sense I'm like right but creatine
usually works but in all these studies
it doesn't and like all I was saying is
like well we should we check yeah it was
like no could be an annoying oh and and
the thing is it that's saying that the
proposed mechanism doesn't make sense
right not that it's not due to some
other mechanism we haven't thought of
yet yeah yeah but anyway yeah I just
think that is a fun little body of
research that is perhaps worth a second
fault mm-hmm okay so the next study I
want to look at is a classic but I want
to talk about it because it relates to
our interview with Brandon I think this
study was briefly mentioned during the
interview but we didn't dig into it a
ton and it is a study that I think a lot
of people are aware of but not a ton and
people generally seem to be interested
in the results because it's pretty cool
the findings are useful and applicable
and also the study itself was really
really well controlled and in a lot of
the sleep research a fair amount of the
studies out there are purely
observational in nature but this was
actually like a tightly well controlled
like Ward's study where they had people
sleeping in the lab every night and
giving them all of their meals to make
sure that everything could be super
tightly controlled so the title of the
study was insufficient sleep undermines
dietary efforts to
adiposity and this was a crossover study
meaning that all of the subjects did
both conditions so they had one
condition where they were sleeping eight
and a half hours per night for two weeks
then they had a washout period and then
they had a condition where they were
sleeping five and a half hours per night
for two weeks which condition each
individual started with was randomized
so it wasn't like you know all long
sleep and then all short sleep half of
them started with the long sleep
condition half of them started with the
short sleep condition and so they were
in bed for either eight and a half hours
or five and a half hours per night the
actual sleep that they attained was
closer to about seven and a half hours
per night versus about five hours and 15
minutes per night so sleep latency like
how long it took to actually fall asleep
was a little bit shorter in the short
sleep condition which makes sense
because you're really tired after only
sleeping five and a half hours per night
so you tend to fall asleep a little bit
quicker but there was still a gap in of
a little more than two hours and how
long they actually slept per night so
the two most the if any sleep
researchers are listening to this this
may make you pull your hair out but to
simplify things quite a bit the two most
important phases of sleep seem to be
slow-wave sleep which is sometimes
called deep sleep and REM sleep so
slow-wave sleep is where a lot of the
physical regeneration during sleep takes
place and REM sleep is more where memory
consolidation takes place and I believe
where you get the growth hormone spikes
during sleep as well and so slow-wave
sleep was actually similar between both
conditions they seemed to get a similar
amount of slow-wave sleep but REM sleep
was significantly greater for the longer
sleep condition so about a hundred and
eight minutes per night versus about 76
minutes per night which is about what
one would expect given the longer sleep
group was getting through about one to
two more sleep cycles per evening
so anyway that's just the sleep stuff in
terms of the actual body comp of X which
is probably what most of you care about
weight loss was similar in both
conditions so what they did in this
study is they reduced so they took the
memory serves they took the the subjects
resting metabolic rate knocked 40% off
of that and that was their calorie
intake per day so pretty large deficit
which makes sense because this was a
pretty short-term study so they needed
to see measurable effects in a two week
time span so pretty big deficit in both
groups but the deficit was the same and
the weight loss was also the same as one
would expect it was about three kilos
per group however in the long sleep
condition the loss of fat free mass was
only about one and a half kilos versus
2.4 kilos in the short sleep condition
and fat loss was about 1.4 kilos
sleeping
eight and a half hours per night versus
point six kilos when only sleeping when
only sleeping five and a half hours per
night so with a pretty big deficit and
three kilos of weight loss the group
only sleeping five and Earth a condition
where they only slept five and a half
hours per night only a fifth of the
weight loss was fat loss which is
[ __ ] brutal and so the yeah that's
not good so basically the weight loss
was half fat mass half fat free mass in
the long sleep condition and mostly fat
free mass in the short sleep condition
which is which is not what you want what
that's a huge ratio of fat free mass to
fat mass yeah that's mostly that sucks
that's really bad like we're I mean
we're talking three kilos of weight loss
in two weeks like that's a lot of weight
loss that's six and a half pounds yeah
and only like a pound of that was actual
fat that's rough
yeah so one potential mechanism that
that may have contributed to those
different effects on body comp was
respiratory quotient was slightly lower
when
participants were sleeping longer so
what respiratory quotient is is it's an
estimate of what type of fuel you're
using to generate ATP so if you have a
RQ of 0.7 that means that all of the
energy you're generating is coming from
fat or virtually all of it if you have
an RQ of 1.0 that means that all of like
virtually all of the energy you're
generating is coming from carbohydrate
or carbohydrate and protein
what is the RQ of protein I know we tend
to not even think about that because we
mostly look at RQ and exercise mm-hmm
and I believe it's isn't it like 0.9
there abouts I was gonna say either
point eight five or point nine but
that's coca I guess yeah so in general
higher RQ means more carbohydrate and/or
protein is where your ATP is coming from
so the lower RQ with the greater sleep
could be indicating you know more of the
actual fuel being oxidized for the
weight losses coming from fat that would
make sense given given what they
actually observed in terms of body
compound one thing to note as well is as
I mentioned this was an inpatient study
where all of the food was supplied to
the participants so they were forced to
maintain a calorie deficit one of the
things they saw though was an increase
in acetylated ghrelin with the short
sleep condition that is a hormone that
generally promotes hunger and so in the
real world what probably would have
happened is the short sleep condition
people would have just ended up eating
more food and probably not actually
losing as much weight and if that didn't
happen you know you're still talking the
same weight loss
way less fat loss and you're gonna be
way hungrier in the process which is not
the sort of conditions you want and
another interesting thing to note is so
Eric previously talked about metabolic
adaptation one interesting thing to note
in this study is resting metabolic rate
actually ended up being lower in the
poor sleep condition or with
with the short sleep so when people are
sleeping eight and a half hours per
night their resting metabolic rate was
about 1,500 calories per day versus
about 1,300 and 90 in the short sleep
condition which like a hundred calories
swing in rmr with not huge changes in
body weight is actually like a fairly
big difference and so one of one of the
things they noted is that even though
weight loss in terms of scale weight was
the same in both groups due to the fact
that there was more fat loss in the
longer sleep condition the actual energy
deficit was greater in the people who
are sleeping more so the energy density
of fat is substantially higher than the
energy density of fat free mass so if
you're losing you know very little fat
even if the scale weight loss is three
kilos the actual energy loss isn't quite
as large so in spite of the same scale
weight loss the energy deficit was
higher in the group sleeping more hours
they also lost less fat free mass just
all-around better so one one thing that
I do want to note about this study is
for strength athletes or physique
athletes hearing about this study
neither condition sounds very good like
you know half of your weight loss coming
from fat free mass is a lot better than
you know most eighty percent of your
weight loss coming from fat free mass
but that's not what anyone really wants
to happen so it is important to note
there wasn't resistance training in this
study they weren't shoveling down 200
grams of protein per day this was a
pretty large energy deficit so you know
all of those standard caveats apply but
there's no reason to think that you know
even if you are training and are eating
protein that you can get away with only
sleeping five hours a night and it and
it's not just I think when people talk
about not sleeping much they tend to
think about it from a behavioral
perspective so you're gonna be hungrier
you're gonna be more likely to eat more
your your you may be a little bit less
motivated to train but also like
mechanistically when everything else is
controlled you still wind up losing more
lean mass and less fat mass due to not
sleeping enough yeah a little real-time
fact-check here the respiratory quotient
of protein different places on the
internet are putting it like 0.8 0.8 to
maybe a little bit north of that but
generally speaking that increase in RQ
is indicative of less reliance on fat as
a substrate so generally speaking not
what you want cool all right so I I am
done with the research review section
now Eric is going to move on to the
research roundup section of the podcast
so research review tends to get a little
bit more in-depth on certain certain
topics or particular studies research
roundup in theory is more just a surface
overview of multiple recent findings
we'll we'll see if we can actually do
that this time around yeah it's supposed
to be like the Sports Center highlight
reel but sometimes we get a bit carried
away but in any case because we had
Brandon on for the the interview portion
this week and we talked a little bit
about sleep I did happen to notice a lot
of very recent papers related to sleep
so for the research roundup just gonna
give a little overview of some of these
recent papers so one of them by Roberts
and colleagues is called extended sleep
maintains endurance performance better
than normal or restricted sleep so what
the study did was there were nine
participants in a crossover trial and
the whole point was to basically
manipulate their sleep habits and see
how it affected their cycling
performance in a timed trial so one
condition was sleep reduction which took
them down to about four point eight
hours of sleep per night for a few days
in a row
the other normal sleep condition was
about 6.8 hours per night which is
pretty typical and then the sleep
extension treatment arm was 8.4 hours a
night what they found not
super surprising but Time Trial
performance was worse with sleep
restriction and it was a little bit
better than normal with sleep extension
which actually is pretty notable that if
you actively tried to get more sleep
than normal in the study it actually did
have a meaningful benefit on that
performance yeah one thing to note just
in general so I'm jumping in here
because sleep extension is something
that I'm all about yeah the the two
periods in my training career where I've
made probably like 70% of my post newbie
gains were periods in time where where I
had a schedule that allowed me to sleep
like 10 11 hours per night so I do i do
legitimately think that sleep extension
is really really good [ __ ] and so some
of the studies that are out there look
at in points that theoretically could
just be related to like psychology and
focus so for example reaction time to a
starting gun for for like getting off
the blocks when swimming free throw
accuracy serving accuracy and tennis
stuff like that but similarly to this
study where you know it's endurance
athletes and they're doing a Time Trial
like that's what endurance race is so
we're talking about tangible benefits in
physical performance that's going to
matter to athletes so some of the
studies that have looked at sleep
extension have seen that as well so
study on basketball players found pretty
notable decreases in sprint times study
on swimmers found that I want to say I
want to say it was 50 meter sprint
performance decreased by like 0.4
seconds which in swimming is a
tremendous amount of time so yeah it's
not just things that could be related to
like psychology or focus or stuff like
that like we do see like clear benefits
and actual physical performance that
athletes care about with reasonably
short-term sleep extension like you
don't have to do it for months at a time
like just a few nights of better sleep
seems to have a pretty
like actually measurable impact on
performance yeah as you alluded to this
study did have some of those extraneous
variables they did find that sleep
restriction made your mood worse which
is the most predictable thing I've ever
heard
it also impaired psychomotor vigilance
it's kind of like a reaction time kind
of thing
and but but yeah probably most
importantly the time trial performance
was significantly affected and like you
were saying the the magnitude of
extension it was only three days and
we're talking about the the total time
in bed being 8.4 hours like everybody
always wants to find like the next
powder and potion that's gonna make them
better it's like just put your phone
down and go to bed yeah now yeah and
like that might be enough to get you
that extra like 60 minutes in bed or
something mm-hmm all right another study
that came out sleep restriction impairs
maximal jump performance and joint
coordination in elite athletes this is
by MA and colleagues and with this one
11 elite cyclists were recruited they
did a one-week baseline with just like
normal sleep habits and then they had
their sleep restricted to four hours a
night for three nights and that's one of
the things about these sleep studies
that you see is like it doesn't take
that long to develop a meaningful sleep
debt it's the Apple nights for nights
and if I could jump in again here as
well so this studies from cherry ma
she's the one who's done most of the
sleep extension research to this point
and what you were talking about people
wanting the powders and potions versus
actually just sleeping more one of the
things you'll note if you look for
research on the sleep extension is
there's not that many studies out there
if you look at studies on sleep
restriction there's a lot of studies out
there I read an interview with sherry ma
from a couple years ago and they they
asked her like you know some of the
sleep extension work you're doing seems
really cool really promising one thing
to note is most of her stuff was done on
so she's from Stanford and it was
actually like they're athletes
so the one on the swimming team Stanford
swimming team
as of I think
four years ago if it was a country would
have finished like fourth and the medal
counts for swimming at the Olympics so
we're talking really [ __ ] good
swimmers and so yeah the interviewer
asked her like why aren't we seeing more
of this research this seems super
promising like aren't athletes super
excited about this she was like yeah
it's just hard to find subjects and so
putting that in context there are
seemingly an unlimited number of people
who are willing to say like ah whatever
yeah I can sleep for hours a night for
three nights but she's having a hell of
a time finding people who are willing to
sleep ten hours a night for three nights
like yeah yeah people are willing to say
like you know whatever I can do more
stuff in my day and just have a few
hours of poor sleep but even among elite
athletes having a hard time finding
people who are willing to sleep a few
extra hours a night for a week or two
people just don't want to sleep they
want to do other [ __ ] but sleeping mores
good stuff and it's a big it's a big
enough problem that we have a hard time
studying it because you can't even
convince people to sleep more for the
good of science I know but it's one of
those things that's so relatable though
cuz like I haven't been sleeping as much
as I should lately mm-hmm and it's like
when it's time to like call it a night
and just go to bed you're like and no I
want to do some other things yeah yeah
and then the next day you're like you
trade it off like staying awake for
another hour and now you just feel like
garbage for like six hours in the middle
of your day and yeah yeah I don't think
that was a good deal but but then it's
the deal you make six six days a week I
was going to say that the next night
you're like well I don't want to go to
bed just yet no I I do the same thing
but it's it's it's wild I mean every
single one of us fails the marshmallow
test every day yeah and that's why
everyone is a complete and utter failure
correct now in this study one of the
things that was cool was you think
vertical jump test you know pretty
simple test you get a height measurement
but they actually did the 3d motion
capture with it and so that they did
find a statistically significant
reduction in jump height due to sleep
restriction from
point four four meters to 0.42 meters
but one of the really interesting things
is that the biomechanical parameters
that they measured changed a little bit
and so I'm not not a bio mechanist but
but what they were talking about a lot
in the discussion was that this sleep
restriction caused these athletes who
are you know well trained athletes
they're not necessarily jumpers so to
speak in terms of their sport but it led
them to deviate from their typical
preferred movement patterns so the
biomechanical parameters changed and the
authors were speculating that this could
have implications when it comes to not
only performance but also injury risk in
athletes so it's not just that they
weren't jumping as high but they were
moving differently the next thing we've
got here is called the effects of sleep
loss on military physical performance by
Clementine Grandal at all and so this
was a review paper looking at a bunch of
different studies on military physical
performance and there's pros and cons of
military research sometimes you feel bad
ethically looking at what they put me
these put these soldiers through it
because you know that it's like they
consented but like kind of right it's
like yeah yeah you guys are kind of just
gonna do this at least I think that's
how I've never done military research
but I would imagine consent looks a
little bit differently in that context I
think you consent to everything that
happens afterwards when you sign up yeah
it's not like a ongoing consent process
to everything that happens to you yeah
but so you'll see a lot of extreme
interventions that take place in
military personnel they also often tend
to lack some of the principles of like a
good randomized control trial you would
typically see with randomization and
blinding because it's just many times
not practical but the thing is like
sometimes this stuff is really important
to do like why is the military studying
these different the crazy
sleep deprivation scenarios because
soldiers are gonna go through them yeah
that happens and so it's almost
unethical to not study it before you put
soldiers into that that situation so
there's a bunch of different studies and
the sleep loss interventions varied a
lot so some of them were just like we're
gonna get you down to five hours of
sleep for five days in a row which is
like not super atypical for like a rough
week at work you know some of the
studies though it'd be like 60 hours
straight of sleep deprivation and one of
them actually said it was up to like a
hundred and two hours straight Jesus
Christ white yeah like some of them were
like pretty terrible man so what they
found there were nine studies in the
review looking at strength and three
looking at muscular endurance and there
were some mixed results in there which
you're gonna find because there is a lot
of heterogeneity in terms of the study
designs that the different outcomes they
measured the different levels of sleep
deprivation but generally speaking they
found reductions in things like hand
grip strength leg extension elbow
flexion things like that when when
looking at strength and that was even in
studies that were doing restriction of
like five hours a night for five nights
so it wasn't just like oh if you stay up
for three days you're not as strong the
trends were really similar for muscular
endurance reductions in elbow flexion
force leg extension push-ups it up
numbers and again that's with just five
hours of sleep for four five days in a
row so when I was reading through that
obviously there's a lot of heterogeneity
a lot of mixed results but even with
very realistic real-world levels of
sleep deprivation they're seeing
measurable impairments of the types of
things that we would do in the gym which
is all the more reason to really
prioritize sleep now there were a couple
caffeine related sleep studies recently
that caught my eye one came out of the
Netherlands but we're gonna give it a
fair we're gonna give it a fair shake
mm-hmm and be objective did we well well
we'll talk about it I I don't I just
don't know if we should actively promote
people from that culture and lifestyle
on this podcast well I'm not really
gonna promote their findings
so it's called evening use of caffeine
moderates the relationship between
caffeine consumption and subjective
sleep quality in students the the author
first author was her / shook maybe and
what they were looking at is it was big
old sample of people with some survey
data and the thing that was interesting
about it was they found that higher
weekly caffeine consumption was only
related to poor sleep quality for people
who didn't consume caffeine in the
evening mm-hmm
even though their total weekly caffeine
consumption was lower than that of the
evening caffeine consumers so it's like
they found this like subjective sleep
disturbance only in people who
specifically didn't have caffeine at
night it's like kind of a convoluted way
to to describe that but I think that
makes sense I mean I phrased it it
doesn't make sense yeah yeah well what
what you said makes sense in that I
literally know what you're describing
but the findings themselves don't make
sense yeah it's like it's kind of a
mouthful but the findings don't make
sense and and honestly they actually
walk there
they basically downplay their own
results mm-hmm they pointed out that
even though higher caffeine intake was
related to poor sleep quality and
students who purposely didn't consume
caffeine in the evening they found that
it was not associated with total sleep
time or the onset of sleep so it's not
like they were laying in bed and
couldn't fall asleep and it's not like
they slept any less mm-hmm they just had
a lower subjective quality score and
then later in the paper they said it's
highly unlikely in terms of like an
actual physiological effect being
observed they say a more plausible
explanation is that this is just they're
observing a self-regulating mechanism
where people who people who know that
they're gonna have no issues sleeping
might be more likely to have caffeine at
night yeah more of like a reverse
causation thing exactly so they think
that the maybe they're observing this
because the people who have who know
that they generally sleep poorly are
like well I better make sure I don't
have calf
at night yeah so so I mean props to the
authors for like they probably didn't
expect to find that in their analysis
and they did and they reported it but
then they were like hey like everybody
chill now hopefully all the like science
journalists out there will actually read
that part and not like go wild with it I
haven't seen any like absurd headlines
about this paper but you could
definitely see that as something where
if people didn't read all those caveats
later they would just be like well key
to better sleep drink your [ __ ]
coffee at 9:00 p.m. yeah you don't have
to cut down on your coffee you just have
to drink it at night that's basically
what the results are I mean and that's
what they do show but but the authors
are like yep that's probably not
probably not how it works
now another paper that caught my eye is
called evening intake of alcohol
caffeine and nicotine night tonight
associations with sleep duration and
continuity among african-americans in
the Jackson Heart sleep study and this
is by Spadola at all and so with this
one they had 785 people in this really
big study average age of sixty three
point seven years I don't wanna get too
into the details on this for a reason
that I'll get to in a second here but
anyway so so it was largely they did
have some survey based data but they
also had active graphs for some
objective sleep measurements at home for
these individuals and the reason I don't
want to get too far into it is because
even looking at the results they were
looking at whether people had caffeine
alcohol or nicotine within the four
hours prior to going to sleep and what
they reported was caffeine had no effect
on the amount of sleep or sleep quality
when it was consumed within four hours
of bed but they found that alcohol and
nicotine did but when you look at the
results like the evening alcohol use was
associated with lower sleep efficiency
but the reduction in sleep efficiency
was only like one percent it was
actually less than one percent it just
happened to be statistically significant
same thing when you look at the nicotine
results nicotine within four hours of
bed was associated with worse sleep
but it was like a 1.8 percent reduction
in sleep efficiency which pretty
negligible and then this w ASO acronym
that went up by six minutes and that's
basically it's defined as the total time
awake after the onset of sleep so there
was like six extra minutes where they
were kind of sitting in bed looking at
the ceiling going like wish I was still
asleep
but six minutes such a negligible change
in my opinion mm-hmm so basically they
found these very small changes related
to alcohol and nicotine but one of the
really big caveats which they are very
open about is they basically had no
information pertaining to the exact dose
and the exact timing mm-hmm so I
understand what they were trying to do
with this kind of big study looking at a
huge sample size but there are certain
research questions that I think are just
much better asked with very direct
experiments on smaller samples yeah and
I think this fits there's certainly
value in some of these larger
observational studies but if you want to
find out if having caffeine before bed
keeps you awake the best way to do that
is give some people caffeine and see how
they sleep yeah yeah like just do it and
so one of the reasons that I'm really
skeptical of some of these observational
studies we just talked about is there's
there's a study from 2013 but it's Drake
at all and they look they did exactly
what we're talking about just bring
people in double-blind give them the
caffeine some amount of time before bed
and see how they sleep and what they
what they were studying is we've
mentioned this study before on the
podcast I'm pretty sure yeah we have but
they either gave them caffeine zero
three or six hours before going to bed
in a double-blind study and they had
subjective measures of sleep quality and
also some objective measures of sleep
quality and the caffeine dose was 400
milligrams which is it's a pretty hefty
dose mm-hmm but generally speaking what
they found was whether
you took at zero three or six hours
before bed
there were statistically significant
disruptions in sleep and not only were
they statistically significant but they
were they were real I mean we're talking
about like latency to sleep with the
placebo was like twenty one minutes of
trying to get to bed all the caffeine
conditions were talking about like 45 to
60 minutes so effectively a doubling or
tripling in the time it takes to get to
bed and then when it talked only to look
at total sleep time total sleep time was
was again like meaningfully reduced like
we're talking like 40 minutes plus yeah
yeah and so when you look at that
compared to the observational studies
looking at some of the stuff when you
consider the rigor of the studies but
also the magnitude of the effects that
we're seeing I just think these these in
lab studies or these more direct
interventions are such a better way to
answer that question when it comes to
this specific question and I think I
have a lot more confidence in those
results and the more rigorously
controlled studies would indicate that
you really ought to be pretty cautious
when it comes to caffeine dosing within
really a handful of hours before bed
mm-hmm
you know we've mentioned on the show
whenever I get a client who has sleep
issues first thing first thing we talk
about is how much caffeine do you have
it and when and if not if nighttime or
evening time caffeine is in the mix you
just got to cut it and see if that fixes
it yeah all right to play us out today
Greg the other day shared on the QA
episode he talked a little bit about his
ice cream recipes and people like that
but not everybody is indulging in ice
cream consumption some of us are trying
to keep things a little bit leaner and
so there's been a lot you're the only
person who had two bowls of ice cream
last night that's private you don't talk
about that oh you can't you can't talk
about other people indulging when you're
when you're the person who indulges the
most that's hypocritical Eric it's
I'm willing to risk my temporary guest
host slot to make sure that this
indignity can't go unchecked okay yeah I
had two servings of ice cream last night
nobody else did but was it good it was
it was [ __ ] it was it was mint
chocolate chip course it was good the
mint was really good the mint was and it
was I think was I I think was dark
chocolate those chips mm-hmm yeah I
could tell those were really good but in
any case keep people like me that are
shredded year-round but wouldn't wanna
dream of going near ice cream we need
chicken recipes and people on the
internet have been clamoring they say
Eric how do you make your chicken your
world-famous chicken how does it work
and it's pretty simple and it's kind of
like I've got a quote here from Forrest
Gump when Bubba is talking about shrimp
pineapple shrimp lemon shrimp coconut
shrimp pepper shrimp shrimp soup etc etc
you can really do anything with shredded
chicken anything so the first step
though is you got to make the chicken
and what you do is you put the chicken
in a crock pot I actually have two crock
pots I've had a two crock pot system for
years because I can make I could
probably make up to like 13 pounds of
chicken breast at once so you put the
chicken in the crock pot and you want to
make sure it's totally submerged in
water and you're gonna put in either a
store-bought packet of taco seasoning or
a bouillon cube or some kind of chicken
broth and so you're gonna put that in
there cook it for eight hours on low
heat and when you wake up it'll be ready
for you and then you're gonna shred it
up right when you take it out of the
crock pot when it's still hot that's the
easiest time to shred it with a couple
of forks you can get the weird little
bear-crawl Bear Claw looking things but
you just use Forks it's fine now step
two you're gonna make the meal and so
what I've got are six
finger-licking absolutely delectable
meals here so the first one is the first
ones Barbic barbecued chicken and what
you do is you take your shredded chicken
you heat it up in the microwave and
and you you put your favorite barbecue
sauce on it and that's pretty much
that's pretty much it but if you wanted
to though if you wanted to you could get
like some baked beans at the store and
maybe like some coleslaw if you had the
calories for it but you know and you
could put it on a bun if you wanted I
guess but barbecued chicken is the
easiest one you just put barbecue sauce
on your chicken that's easy
chicken parmesan this is one of my
favorite meals I make oh so what I do is
I take the chicken I put it in a bowl
heat it up in the microwave I put some
kind of pasta sauce on it and some
mozzarella cheese and then I'll it just
a little bit of Parmesan cheese on top
of that and that's chicken parmesan if
you want you could also put some
vegetables in it what I'll do is I'll
get like frozen spinach or froze and or
frozen mushrooms and I'll heat those up
and put it in the chicken parmesan and
be pretty good chicken lasagna this
one's really good [ __ ]
chicken lasagna is when you make your
chicken parmesan but you just put
fat-free cottage cheese it I've done
that where's the lasagna with their chi
chi's weird the noodles you don't know
it's Lokar like noodles what lasagna
recipe uses cottage cheese some do
instead of like ricotta no it's either
ricotta or a bechamel nice cottage Oh
God Erick chicken pizza this one's good
chicken pizza you you get some naan
bread like naa n and you put some pizza
sauce on it some of your shredded
chicken cover that with cheese put in
the oven 400 degrees and you're good
once the cheese melts you're ready to go
and I actually approve of that one that
one's not good yeah that one's really
good there's also I don't know what to
call this I basically just put like a
California mix of vegetables so
cauliflower broccoli and carrots and
then I put the shredded chicken in there
with some Italian dressing maybe a
little mozzarella cheese that's pretty
good and then chicken talk
now chicken tacos I have every single
day I've had chicken tacos every day for
the last probably four months I would
estimate usually for lunch and dinner
actually and it's pretty simple you just
you get some kind of rice to vegetables
in the frozen section at the grocery
store you heat those up put your
shredded chicken in there put it on a
tortilla some cheese sour cream salsa
hot sauce Gregg make some homey and help
hot sauce that's really really good but
when I run out of that I just get the
store-bought stuff and it's it's alright
I guess so yeah those are I mean that's
what is that six different chicken meals
to keep you busy for the next couple
years when you're prepping you know not
every well you're busy I'm busy we don't
have time to make all these elaborate
ice creams and custards and whatever
else they're making so we just make
basic stuff with shredded chicken and it
works well and happy cooking that
lasagna brings me physical pain it's not
good you can't call it lasagna man you
can but it's just not good the problem
is the cottage cheese is too much liquid
you you're you're going to receive a
visit from the ghost of Garfield past
and it's not gonna be pretty
so I do want to like sometimes we're
sarcastic on the show I want to be very
very clear that this is literally how I
eat and I'm not being sarcastic and Greg
you can you can attest to this so if
you're out there and when Greg's talking
about all these meals and it just makes
you feel tired and you're like God
cooking sounds horrible I want you to
know that I'm with you and it's it's
okay for us to be this way Greg admit
that it's okay for us to be this way
dude you can cook good stuff and it's
not that hard
well there's two different schools of
thought we've we've given both to the
audience how they can choose team Eric
or team team Greg sure all right I think
that does it for today's episode right
yes sir so on the interview portion of
today's episode we've got an interview
with dr. Brandon Robert
he's got a PhD in some exercise science
related field he did a lot of work with
like pretty nitty-gritty
muscle biology so this guy knows a lot
about muscle physiology we talked to him
a little bit about his recent
bodybuilding contest preparation we
talked about some muscle physiology
research and then we talked a little bit
about sleep as well so that interview
will will start playing after the music
as always thank you for listening
take care
[Music]
all right welcome back to the stronger
by science podcast this is the host eric
Trexler I'm here with temporary guest
host Greg knuckles and for the interview
portion of today's episode we are joined
by dr. Brandon Roberts Brandon thank you
for joining us thanks for having me guys
I am curious when you're gonna replace
your ghost you need anybody to take that
up yeah I've been getting a lot of
applications a lot of really strong
applications so I mean it's kind of hard
to find time in the day to get through
all of them but there's a lot of really
good ones he's gonna be replacing his
co-host around the same time he becomes
interested in replacing his job yeah I
mean all options are on the table yeah
including the nuclear option
exactly so Brandon there's a lot of
stuff we want to talk to you about
tonight but before we get into that you
are a competitive bodybuilder aside from
all of your academic interests or I
guess in conjunction with your academic
interests and your most recent
competition was like four days ago right
yeah yeah so it was four days ago and I
was fortunate enough to take first and
men's overall bodybuilding and it was a
I had a blast and so is this year this
is not your first prep is it no so this
is my second season I did two shows in
2016 and then I generally try to do two
to three shows a season but I would say
this is the first one where I feel
really good about everything and I'm
like okay I have a decent physique
awesome well I mean yeah I saw the
pictures you looked really great and
congratulations on picking up the win
and it sounds like you've got another
competition coming up soon right yeah so
we're gonna try to get one in at the end
of the month um not that it's the
end-all be-all but you know every
amateur bodybuilder wants to go pro and
I'd like at least a shot at a pro card
so that's that's the the ultimate goal
if it doesn't happen that's totally fine
yeah I mean good luck with that I don't
want you to
psych yourself out but if you want some
really lofty goals you can try to go pro
in two separate sports and which is what
I've done and a lot of people are very
very impressed by that and they call me
Bo Jackson pretty frequently which I'm
I'm happy to have that nickname I think
it's I think it sells me short a little
bit but in any case Bo did some good
work - yeah I was saying actually
thinking I listen that podcast right
well my walk today and I was thinking
you were more of a Deion Sanders type
what do you what do you think about that
you know Eric Helms and I talked about
this and I think Helms is kind of a
pretty boy Helms is really flashy he's
kind of unlikable I think he's more of a
Dion and I'm more of a badass and I
think we arrived at that conclusion got
it got it that make sense Greg you were
probably there when we chatted about
that in London we were there for the
European powerlifting conference and
kind of sorted all this stuff out I
don't think I was there for that
conversation well we got to the bottom
of it now Brandon I always like to ask
people this just cuz I'm curious about
the variability between people your
current prep what's the lowest that your
caloric intake got yeah so I ended up
taking pretty dang hard the four days
before the refeed and I was sitting
about like 1400 calories for three or
four days came back out of prep this
weekend and hit two more days 1400 I
don't know and I don't know that I want
to stay that low very long so we'll kind
of see how it goes you said you got down
to 1300 for a few days yeah yeah not
something I would recommend for everyone
oh that's brutal what did you eat on it
on a day of 1,300 calories oh man I have
I have a whole like plan I eat this the
same stuff every day basically so it's
like egg whites and oatmeal
not much oatmeal I have tuna with Greek
yogurt and carrots and then I usually
has some like chicken and vegetables and
protein bar and some vegetables more
vegetables no that's kind of it so what
what we're kind of daily protein intake
we talking about somewhere between 190
and 200 grams so 200 grams of protein on
1300 calories that is you know when that
when they say if it fits your macros I
don't think those are the macros they
had in mind
no definitely no it it's uh it got to
the point where and I actually used it
just now what I'll time my carb intake
around important tasks in the day so if
I have a meeting or I want to write part
of a paper our grant like I'm working on
this big grant right now and I'm like i
I've got like three hours where I was
productive oh man I've been there it's
not a good place to be but but I I know
what you're saying man it it's finally
the spot where nutrient timing becomes
critical when you have to try to write
something important when your brain
doesn't work now with this prep what
have been your your favorite and your
least favorite parts so my probably my
least favorite part sir I
I went on a couple different trips and I
loved the trips but I hate not knowing
exactly or being able to prep the exact
food that I want it just makes it here
it's a little bit harder so you know NSE
a conference went to Mexico went on a
two-week tour of the west coast for
vacation and so it's hard to enjoy those
things I've gotten a lot better at it
but that's my least favorite part is
having to sacrifice stuff that would
normally be like I'd have way more fun
yeah and I was actually with you we were
both in Mexico and then we were both at
the NSC a conference there like a few
weeks apart and it was like every time I
saw you you looked completely different
you're in that like last phase of prep
where every three weeks you're like a
completely different person yeah yeah
and I'm actually shaved now so I'm
looking it more different I was sporting
a beard to cover up the prep face for a
while yeah normally when you talk to a
bodybuilder deep in prep the two things
that come up a lot our hunger and then a
horn hormone issue
and also sleep issues what seems to be
the toughest this time around so I get I
definitely get hangry
I had to cloten of the important
personal relationships no no and my wife
you've been approved of the second
competition which I'm you know always
grateful for but I have I've done better
this prep I would say my first love my
pet prep news at 16 I didn't sleep very
well at all like I was sleeping like
four or five hours a night I was super
productive but just couldn't sleep and
then I think hormonal E I'm fine I mean
my hormones are in the tank but that's
pretty normal so and I'm sleeping better
so when you say hormonal you're fine
does that just mean that hormonal E
you're not fine but you're okay with it
yes that's exactly correct that's yeah I
can't do anything about it and I know my
you know test is really low and
everything else is messed up so I'm just
like yeah okay whatever yeah I mean I'm
not trying to be a smartass but honestly
my most recent prep was my smoothest and
I think the difference was I went into
it expecting just general [ __ ] and chaos
and so when I found it I was like oh
yeah this is fine it's not that I felt
any better it was just I had emotionally
made peace with my existence at that
point now we mentioned that we were both
in Mexico at an event down there and one
of the things that you talked about was
response heterogeneity this is a topic
I've seen you talk and write about on a
few different occasions so for listeners
who have maybe never even heard the term
response heterogeneity what is it and
why is it important okay so it's an it's
it's a really long term and I generally
shorten it to just responsiveness but
it's how different people adapt to the
same stimulus and that can be nutrition
training whatever you know your your
studying
you just see that obviously not
everybody adapts the same and sometimes
if you look at you know data and studies
or have enough athletes or whatnot you
can even see that nobody is actually
changing kind of at the average why do
you take it upon yourself to talk about
it when you go to events why have you
written about it like like what does
this mean for the the person at home who
trains people or is training themselves
or just likes to kind of stay up to date
with the literature yeah so I've been
quite fascinated with it and that's why
I went and did first three years my
postdoc with vomit who kind of made his
name in this this area but I just I
wanted to figure out why people just you
could see massive differences in how
they respond to the exact same thing
under pretty much the same circumstances
and and take bad information and turn
everyone or relate it to hey you know
you're you're one of my athletes or
whatever and or maybe you have your own
athletes and you have this one athlete
who's just not adapting as well as
everyone else right so so then you can
change a lot of variables and and you
can probably use a year trying to figure
it out but maybe they just don't respond
as well or maybe they respond super well
right so I just wanted to try to figure
out kind of the science behind that
and honestly I I've learned a lot but
there's no like straight answer so would
would you say that the primary thing
holding most people back is that they
just don't want it bad enough is that
that's what I learned in middle school
football and that's uh that's proven
pretty true for me throughout most of my
life people either succeed or they're
lazy moochers is is that the case with
resistance training as well I was gonna
say there's also a segment of the
population that has not run enough
Sprint's to develop mental toughness yet
which is a key part of that
but ideally without access to water well
yeah if you get the water then you don't
develop all the toughness water is for
cowards water makes you weak waters for
washing blood off your Jersey you better
not get any blood on your Jersey do you
care to comment Brandon
I remember those uh high school football
and soccer days I remember that very
very deeply and no I'm sure there's some
element involved but maybe not that
extreme on a serious note do you ever do
you ever hesitate to bring this up when
you're first working with a client like
do you ever have fear that you might
plant the idea that the second they
reach kind of a sticking point in the
program that they're just gonna conclude
like well apparently I'm screwed this
ain't for me time to pack it in um I
usually do wait a little while I think
you can't plant seeds but also when you
first getting someone that they're
really really likely to make some
progress even just from the different
programming if they're you know coming
from a different coach or if their solo
coaching themselves whatever so yeah I
usually wait at least six to eight weeks
when it comes to response heterogeneity
we've defined it but I think one of the
things that's really helpful is putting
some kind of magnitude with it to give
people an idea of when we look at
responses to training whether it's
hypertrophy or strength gains like what
kind of magnitudes of variability do we
see in responses to training yeah so
there's quite a large magnitude if we
want to talk maybe relative terms
because that's a little easier you can
see 10% below the average all the way up
to 20 to 30 percent above the average so
that's just the ability to change from
baseline you know losing strength maybe
or gaining 25% strength in the study or
something so it's pretty wide and if you
look at
different measures so you know if you're
looking at muscle fibers or something
like that can be quite a large
difference we had one person in a study
lost like 80 percent of muscle fiber
sighs and I'm looking at the data and I
was like ya know I think that's that's
not right so it can be what quite large
so they lost 85 percent of their fiber
size with at the ashram and error yeah
definitely okay cuz I mean sometimes
I'll look at these studies that show
individual responses and you'll see
somebody that over the course of a
resistance training program they get
weaker or they have a reduction in
muscle size are there people who are
having real genuine reductions in muscle
size in response to a program that is
designed to promote hypertrophy or do
you think those are instances of a poor
response plus some downward trending
measurement error yeah so I mean I would
be more prone to say it's a it's just a
poor response and met a lot of
measurement error a lot of people don't
report kind of the repeatability
measures but in their papers anymore and
like I was just reviewing a paper
yesterday on hypertrophy and I was like
well so what are your like
inter-relational correlations for ICC's
it definitely butchered that that's okay
and they never had an e I'm like well
that's pretty important to know your
error rate right I'm like if you want to
know true change you need to have some
idea of what your error is well I mean
if it's something like a muscle
thickness or a cross sectional area
unless you're just horrendous ly bad at
doing an ultrasound shouldn't
measurement error for that the
reasonably low yeah so in an ultrasound
for sure
I mean that's pretty I don't want to say
crude because I actually really like
ultrasounds for measurements but some of
the muscles that we see that aren't
measured very often so like the glue
or something may have generally lower
kind of repeatability measures and and
you know if you've been doing
measurements for a decade
obviously you're better at it than
someone who just started to so I think
there are a lot of factors that you can
definitely control but I do always like
to just see that clearly responses are
quite variable obviously any time you
look at a study there's going to be some
degree of measurement error kind of
baked into the cake there but certainly
responses genuinely are quite variable
between people what exactly is the root
cause of this pretty wide range of
variability so I I think there's no one
root cause but I can I can give you a
number of things that I've seen in
person and then just kind of speculate a
little bit but I mean obviously there's
genetics and epigenetics on top of that
which we can't control and you know you
can't really pick your parents maybe you
get lucky maybe you don't now you can
control effort which we kind of
mentioned so if you're giving a high
amount of effort that probably helps in
studies nutrition plays a large role
adherence right did people come in and
do all their sessions or you know as an
athlete are you hitting all of your
sessions are you skipping like like day
every fifth week or something so you
have those and then there are also kind
of how even different trainers in the
same gym will train you to go into
failure or not go into failure like you
have some RPE type differences there so
I think it's a lot of little things
adding up rather than you know just like
I have gene X I can't hypertrophy
do you have any hope that we're really
gonna nail down those genetic
determinants of training responses or do
you think there's so much you know
because it's not like that we're gonna
find the singular gene that explains 95%
of a particular training adaptation you
wouldn't think I mean do you think
there's any hope of trying to unravel
the the the web of genes that that are
gonna be really dictating a lot of these
responses I mean if you look at some of
the weight loss studies they've they're
kind of ahead of the game compared to
some of the exercise studies and even
then like you're looking at maybe a five
to seven percent max explanation from
one specific gene or whatnot and I and I
don't know that we'll ever really figure
it out there is a study that's going to
attempt that starting sometime soon
that's recruiting like 3,000 subjects oh
yeah it's good yeah yeah so that's in
your lab so that is it's a it's a nash
nationwide study called motor pack
actually on the website it's pretty
public it's NIH funded and so they're
going to have last time that changes
slightly every every so often but last
time I heard about it they are going to
have a resistance arm an endurance arm
and a control arm and have I think it's
12 to 16 weeks of training and do pretty
much every omics you can think of with
the best people in the country and then
also do muscle fat blood I think there's
even some microbiome stuff in there
basically that you're taking a whole
bunch of tissue from people and paying
them a whole bunch of money and then
they're gonna they're gonna compare that
and have about 3,000 people and the
exercise groups and think like 500 or
1000 in the control group so yeah
that'll that's you know ten years down
the road but that'll be good chunk of
answers hopefully I tell you what we've
talked about this on the
the show how critical it's going to be
to start moving toward doing more
multicenter trials where you've got
several different research groups
collaborating and trying to make some of
these larger sample sizes happen I think
this is one of the great examples where
we're not going to figure this out
9 subjects at a time you know what I
mean yeah we can't treat this like
creatine and bench press we got to
collaborate and put this stuff together
but man that's really exciting it's
probably gonna be ages until they're
done with that I'd imagine yeah yeah so
I mean you probably won't see any data
out of that study for like you know
eight years or so but it'll be pretty
cool and and they're even having where
it's not one lab so they're banking all
the tissue and you have to apply almost
like a grant for tissue samples to run
your certain analyses and do some
studies and stuff but it should be
pretty awesome so they're gonna
essentially sell human flesh to the
highest bidder so it sounds like yeah
something like that
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna take that as a
challenge from now on all business
proceeds if stronger by science are
going to go towards buying human flesh
and farming out these analyses so we can
get the first scoop that'd be pretty
cool we know people with the skill set
to actually run these analyses so we
could start like a GoFundMe sure okay
we're trying to buy human tissue I'm
sure that would be that can't violate
their Terms of Service or anything start
a patreon account where the the art
we're producing is the acquisition of
human tissue samples that seems like a
really good strategy so Brandon just
based on what we do know right now what
do seem to be some of the things we
currently know that that seemed to
predict at least to some degree whether
someone's going to respond well or
poorly to training oh yes that's a great
question because we do have a couple of
question get [ __ ] Mary
that have not only outlined yeah so
there's actually a review that I'll
refer you to and talk about it but it's
a it's by Mike Roberts not so not me the
other Roberts and it summarizes
everything really nicely and one of the
things with we kind of know is that
those with more satellite cells in their
muscles at baseline tend to respond
better so that's a study from things
like 2006 or 2007 there's also a good
bit of data to show that you know those
with more ribosomes and ribosomes kind
of are part of muscle protein synthesis
right so if you have more I bazooms at
baseline before you start training you
tend to get a better response and
hypertrophy outcomes I think there's
even a study with like androgen
receptors from Stu Phillips that demo
our androgen receptors has a better
response which you know a lot of this
stuff you're like yeah no that makes
sense and then there's one with
capillary content which you know
supplies the muscle with blood which
again you think you have enough of all
these things you're probably prone to
respond a little better that makes sense
yeah and when it comes to being in the
fortunate position of having all these
things in place a baseline that that
basically is coming down to picking her
parents it sounds like is that right
yeah basically
alright the people that follow Brandon
know that he's an expert in muscle
physiology he's got a really extensive
skill set when it comes to some of the
bench science involved in exercise
science and there was a very relevant
study that came out this year by Cody
Han a friend of ours and you covered
this in a previous issue of mass and why
don't you take it from here if you want
to just give us a Greg if you want to
give us a little summary of what the
study showed this was a secondary paper
published based off of experiment where
were the main results of
published previously and essentially
what they did is they had people train
for six weeks with increasing training
volume the biopsies they took were
vastus lateralis biopsies so the only
training relevant to that that they were
doing was squat training training three
times a week building up from I want to
say maybe 12 total sets of 10 was 60%
across the week on week 1 up to maybe 36
that's per week like pretty close to 40
sets per week of squats by week 6 took
some biopsies looked at a bunch of
various different things but one of the
couple of the things they looked at were
density of actin and myosin proteins and
several other things as well but the
density of actin and myosin proteins
seemed to decrease in the subjects that
showed robust hypertrophy thus leading
to the conclusion that they were
probably experiencing sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy or in other words an
increase in muscle fiber size with a
concomitant decrease in the density of
contractile proteins and so Brandon
given that this this type of work kind
of falls within your area of expertise
what do you make of this paper yeah so I
you know probably even three or four
years ago I wasn't sure about
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy there just
wasn't a whole lot of data there you
know there are some older papers and we
wrote about that in the review that Cody
lied and that I do I really like coding
and Mike Roberts over at Auburn and so
so I'm not sure what to make of it but
it does make sense and when he first
were first chatting about this data I
was like okay well obviously it's it's
like
glycogen changes right so you know they
then they were like well actually no
they're not really new Clayton changing
changes in any of the and the responder
status and I'm like okay well what about
mitochondria right maybe these people
are doing 60% 1rm that's a little more
what you would consider metabolic maybe
maybe they're adapting more through the
metabolic pathways and then straight
kind of myosin and actin changes and
long behold that's not it either and
they they actually used a number of
different measures to look at these
changes and so you know they kept
scraping and scraping and they did some
proteomics which I've done proteomics
and I actually today for father we
analyze their data and I was like now
this is like super legit and I I just
think that you know muscle is really
plastic and this is totally feasible
like I've seen it in enough studies now
and kind of wrap my head around it that
maybe this is something that happens so
that the or an adaptation to the nucleus
to be able to get message like out or in
easier or less easy and then it adapts
afterwards to make it more easy so the
my own nuclear domain theory kind of
playing in there or maybe it's a
long-term adaptation I'm not really sure
but I wouldn't like to see and as this
is me as a scientist just you know hey I
always want to see more I'd like to see
like a longer-term study maybe with the
not a more reasonable exercise
prescription but something more people
would do how about that yeah because I
mean toward the end of that program they
were doing a significant amount of work
per session like it it looked pretty
brutal yeah yeah that would put me on
the floor for sure yeah I think I think
I want to say they were doing either 12
or 14 sets of ten twice per week and
like yeah it was only sixty percent one
max but still like you're talking about
doing a hundred and twenty hundred and
forty squats per session like unless
you're talking about an empty bar that's
gonna be hard yeah yeah so Greg I think
your take generally speaking from the
study was that it was fairly solid
evidence that sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
was occurring but the thing that's a
little bit uncertain is what is the
functional utility of that and is there
any way to kind of target that response
is that an accurate summary of that
pretty much yeah Brandon are you kind of
do you have the same viewpoint in this
paper that it looks like we're we're
focusing in on some evidence that
relates to sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
occurring yeah yeah I feel I mean I feel
pretty confident I've so I've done all
of these assays that they did and the
only caveat right in this paper is
follow-up paper is the sample size so I
yeah that's easy low-hanging fruit but
you know you do have to look at the data
and you say okay well there's a little
bit of variability that looks like maybe
a couple guys were going up couple guys
are going down but that's just me being
super picky so I mean my my take on this
whole thing is that if you're asking the
question of can sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
exist like like is it a phenomenon that
can occur really all you need to
disprove that something can't happen is
a case where where it happens so like
this study reported significant mean
differences but they were kind of like
high-ish p-value so below 0.05 but not
too far below but there were quite a few
individuals who had very substantial
decreases in actin and myosin density so
unless we are laboring under the
assumption that there was very very
large measurement error in every single
one of those individuals it
one of them experienced sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy so like I feel like just you
know one example is enough to establish
that a phenomenon exists and then the
next question is you know how common is
it can we purposefully bring it about
etc but you know I think that the study
was more than sufficient to demonstrate
that it is something that can exist and
I don't think we necessarily need to see
group level changes to be confident in
that yeah I mean I think that's pretty
fair it I've never really thought of it
that way but um yeah that does make
sense in this this there's a lot of
evidence in this paper so I agree with
you there Brandon one of the reasons we
brought you on for this particular
interview is because we know you've got
a really extensive sleep article in the
works and sleep has been something that
I think Greg and I are both pretty
fascinated in because we have generally
terrible sleep habits and are intrigued
by how they ruin our lives so first
things first why exactly do we sleep why
is it so important to us as organisms um
well if you if you don't sleep you die
Eric but outside of that I don't know
that we we have an exact reason I know
that it restores you know a lot of our
systems endocrine and metabolic it's
critical for learning so it does a lot
of different things so I'll just kind of
leave it at that and say it's sleep does
a lot of good but I don't know that
there's one unified theory of hey we
need sleep because of this my kind of
simple statement is we need sleep
because if we won't die if we don't have
it when it comes to you know a more
focused look at sleep obviously
subjectively one would think that poor
sleep would impact performance and maybe
even have negative effects on body
composition what is the Reese
tell us about how sleep plays in with
performance in athletic tasks yeah so it
looks like and I I was kind of shocked
when I saw this but in an acute setting
so right if you if you have restricted
sleep for one night or something you
just have bad night of sleep or maybe
pull an all-nighter acute strength at
least is not really affected it's really
only until the second or third night of
kind of restricted sleep and even at
that you have to have quite restricted
sleep like four or five hours to where
you'll see strength performance changes
but when you look at other outcomes like
for athletes that are important like
reaction time or judgment or things like
that it's pretty much one bad night of
sleep can make a difference you know
there's there studies that also look at
like kind of motor learning and then at
night asleep can affect how you learn a
task which makes sense so yeah you can
you couldn't have some pretty big
detriments from it what about effects on
body composition I mean if you're
chronically sleeping poorly how might
that carry over into your physique yeah
so there there's a number actually I
think there's there's probably two or
three studies on body composition and
what ends up happening is if you're
trying to lose weight you end up losing
less body fat than you would hope and
losing more muscle in the process of
dieting basically so if your if your
sleep restricted and on a diet tend to
lose more muscle there are a few
metabolic changes that happen so by the
composition of it's affected by a lot of
things when you have reduced your
appetite and hunger go up right so maybe
that affects your body composition
through energy and your intake there's a
number of studies that show you know
you're more prone to have snacks and I
fatty foods and those are you know
easier to consume at high doses so
yeah it can definitely play a role in
body composition especially over the
long term one of the things that's
always troubled me is you know we're
both body builders and when you're doing
a contest prep like you mentioned low
sleep is associated with you know less
fat loss and more loss of lean mass and
so when you're prepping for a
bodybuilding show you're thinking okay I
definitely want to optimize my sleep to
avoid that and fun fact the more you're
asleep the less you're awake to try to
eat which is a suitable thing but for me
I know whenever I get really deep into
prep I struggle severely trying to get a
good night's sleep if I can get four or
five hours in a row I'm thrilled with
that did you in the process of writing
this article have you gotten any
information or found any kind of
evidence about why that is like why when
we're super lean and energy restricted
why does it become so hard to get sleep
so I'm gonna explain this simply because
I have not found great evidence although
you know there's the one bodybuilding
study that shows what kind of not reduce
ly but poor sleep habits we call it but
you know as far as I can tell I think
it's almost a drive to eat is keeping
you awake yeah at some point right the
idea that maybe your body is trying to
scavenge for food even though you're
just sitting there so I have not found
any kind of good hormonal evidence other
than you know that the appetite stuff
but yeah there's just not a whole lot
out there now we see that with rodent
models right like when you when you
restrict their food intake and you under
feed them their activity level actually
goes up because they they kind of start
like freaking out and foraging around
for food right yeah yeah and we I saw
I've actually done a few nutrient
deprivation studies in rodents and they
run around their cage
and they pull on their their cage tabs
and make a lot of noise so yeah we do
have that and I didn't get too much into
the road and literature and this article
that just you know it's kind of more for
humans and general population and stuff
but I to take a look at that because I'm
actually working on another article of
equal length already
I mean it's fascinating stuff now
getting a little bit more practical with
it art are there people who just need
less sleep than others or do we all need
that kind of standard eight hours give
or take um well I think or I would you
know we hope that we need less sleep
than others right okay you're sitting
here and you're like yeah we average
maybe six hours a night or something and
and there's a little bit of Hope in you
that's like nah there's that's fine I'm
fine I'm different but it doesn't really
seem like that's the case there are some
people who have a specific gene
I think it's called de to see who get by
on less sleep but even that's like 6.5
hours so not really I think what happens
is people just adjust to reduce sleep by
kind of the lack of an effect but they
don't realize that they're
sleep-deprived and so they adopt that
they're like underperforming you know
whether it's in terms of their energy
level they're cutting their cognitive
level performance whatever that's just
their new baseline like they're used to
being underslept yes exactly and and
what one of the things that happens when
you don't sleep enough is your self
evaluation of your performance starts
becoming increasingly less accurate so
there was a study I can't remember
exactly what they were measuring but I
remember they had people sleeping six
hours per night for I think five or six
nights in a row and they saw that on the
tasks that they were measuring them on
performance dropped off pretty linearly
day after day after day after day so you
know they were worse on day 2 than day 1
worse on day 3 than day 2 were Sunday 4
than day 3 etc but when they asked the
subjects how do you think you're
performing they accurately said they
thought they were worse on day 2 than
day 1 but from that point on they
thought that oh yeah I'm about the same
as I was yesterday
so they had like five days where they
were performing worse and worse and
worse and thought that they were still
performing about as well as they did
with just one night of six hours of
sleep so they're like a drunk person
doing karaoke they're like yeah I think
I nailed that pretty alright yeah pretty
much now so a lot of times you ask that
question and the that you answer under
like under the kind of perspective when
you ask does everybody need the same
amount of sleep you think can I get away
with less but let me ask that question a
slightly different way do assets need
more sleep than the general public
yeah so it's kind of the recommendations
in the literature for athletes are like
eight to nine hours and it doesn't seem
and I'll say anecdotally too it doesn't
seem like more sleep is detrimental
especially for someone who's you know
high level athlete so I would I would
say they need more and let them have as
much as they want one of the things one
of just like the lay press articles I
think that stuck with me the most in
recent years is so I'm a really big NBA
fan and the NBA has a famously tough
travel schedule like even though they
play about half as many games as
baseball players too they're rarely
doing you know back to backs or like
three games in the same city in a stand
or whatever like they're always flying
coast to coast and so one of the
problems with the NBA is like huge
drop-offs in performance and big
increases in injury risk as the season
wears on and there was an interview with
like trainers and strength coaches from
several NBA teams and one of the things
they mentioned was that in their opinion
the biggest change in the NBA that was
helping players you know stay
injury-free and still perform well into
the playoffs was the invention of tinder
because prior to tinder you know you're
in another city you just played a game
you want to have you want to have some
fun with whatever people you're
attracted to after the game you have to
go to the bar chat with people bring
them back to your room etc with tinder
they could just like basically have an
assistant hit up people on tinder and
say like hey want to come back to my
room after the game and that like
streamlined the process they estimated
that had let people that it let the
players get about an extra hour to of
sleep after away games because they
weren't having to go out and chat up
girls at the bar and they were like yeah
that's honestly even making such a big
difference as the season is worn on
which i think is super cool and the
other thing that so another thing that
I've noticed is that we're seeing a lot
more athletes than we used to perform
really well really late into their
careers and oftentimes those athletes at
least anecdotally report that they sleep
a ton so like LeBron James is still
playing better basketball than anyone
his age has any right to play and during
the season I think he says he sleeps
like 10 or 11 hours a night
in general Roger Federer is playing
better tennis than anyone his age has
ever played in the modern era he says he
sleeps between 10 and 12 hours a night
my favorite is Paula Radcliffe who I
believe still holds the female world
record in the marathon famously slept 14
hours a day she would sleep 10 hour
tonight get up run Matt for hours
through the day get up run again wind
down a little bit in the evening sleep
another 10 hours repeat the process so I
wonder I wonder one of the things I've
noticed looking at the literature is
like there's only what you you'd know
this better than me maybe three or four
studies looking at sleep extension in
athletes and they tend to find really
positive results but I wonder if we
actually do know kind of where that
upper in lies like their recommendations
like you said are eight to nine hours a
night but I do wonder especially for
really really high performers in really
strenuous sports if that's even higher
like up in the 10 plus hour range
yeah so there there are a number of
studies and there's actually just one
just publish on sleep extension where
they essentially try to increase sleep
by it's like two hours per night
assuming they're just like getting seven
hours and they all find mark like pretty
big improvements in performance and I
think that's probably true that you know
nine to ten hours is probably more
likely it's like I didn't realize you're
a huge NBA fan because I'm also a
ridiculously big NBA fan and my podcast
in my um just a Segway for a second
click Padma podcasts are like half an be
a half fitness hell yeah I enjoy that
that date it well Gregg is really just a
tinder fan and tinder brought him today
you're gonna you're gonna get me in
trouble because I was married before
tinder was invented so let's make sure
we get this episode up before Lyndsey
has a chance to listen to it yeah we'll
do that so on the topic of sleep one of
the things that comes up a lot is the
idea of chrono types so some people
being more night owls other people being
more early risers so can you give us
like a brief description of what chrono
type chrono types are and then how they
essentially matter in relation to sleep
yeah
so donor types are basically your
preference on when you like to sleep and
complete your activity so that's a whole
lot of nothing but early morning early
types basically prefer to do stuff in
the morning they wake up earlier we're
kind of the later kernel types like are
based in the evening right so it makes
sense most people actually though they
fall somewhere in the middle so true
morning types are like 15% and true
evening types or there's only like 15
population and then what's the second
part of your question so 70% of the
people kind of fall in the middle but
but so the research does kind of
indicate that this is a real biological
thing it's not just kind of a social
construct of people who say I just don't
like going to bed early I mean we can
identify these people and they truly do
function better when they're aligned
with their preferred chronotype yeah so
as far as I can tell from the literature
that is true and you could even take a
so my my article I have like a link for
an automated quiz so I took it and I'm
kind of a I think it was early morning
type but I I also think there is some
social construct to it maybe a little
bit at least and so have you looked at
any studies that attempt to shift people
away from their preferred chronotype
yeah that's that's what I'm interested
in like how how plastic are Crona types
or like to what degree are they
hardwired honestly I did not see any of
those I thought that not that they don't
exist but I didn't look for any kind of
type shifting but overall there's kind
of this idea and then replaced this with
that question that um
people who play certain sports better
have a certain chronotype and I don't I
don't know if that's true
but I would definitely be interested it
I kind of adapt somebody's gonna type
see what happens
now that you've looked at some of the
literature on chronotype
do you find it really weird when people
brag about waking up early oh yeah
because I've never understood that like
I guess that maybe it's because I don't
work on like a normal work schedule
anymore but when people like yeah I woke
up at 4:00 in the morning I'm like whoa
guess what I stayed up till 3:00
we both had quite a day didn't we mine
just was darker at the end yeah and I
said what some of the undergrads that I
used to mentor and Dermot PhD they would
always feel bad because like we would
get to lab early like 6:30 or something
ridiculous and they would come in at
like 10:00 or so like yeah I just got
out of bed I made it here you know best
I could and oh my god well don't feel
bad like Kelly we got last night oh my
god I don't know like two or three and
I'm like well you see you're just
shifting your day backwards like that's
totally okay for most people especially
in college yeah all the people who are
like really stoked about themselves for
waking up at like 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning it's like at 8:00 p.m. they're
functionally useless like asleep before
the Sun sets in the summer so I had a
question for you
you hear a lot of mixed opinions about
this a topic that comes up a lot in
sleep is napping hour naps advisable I
mean do they help you recover from a
lack of sleep so I would say natcher
always a good thing
as far as I've read and that's there a
ton of studies on naps there there
aren't as many studies looking at
performance in naps but I think there
are enough to say even if it's just from
a learning perspective or trying to
maybe catch up a little bit on sleep as
long as it doesn't interrupt your other
sleep so like in your nighttime sleep I
haven't seen no detrimental effects of
mass now there's got to be a point where
at some point the nap if it's long
enough in duration it probably probably
would start interfere
with your nighttime sleep what do you
think yeah and there are some studies
that have tried to figure out like okay
well you know naps are good that's been
established for a while let's try to
figure out what the best nap length is
and most of them you know it's like 10
to 20 minutes ideally this is kind of
funny
the the best time to take a nap is when
you're sleepy right after lunch right so
that you have that a post more deal dip
that hit set at the office or you know
wherever you're at but if you're not
gonna do what seems to be like a 10 to
20-minute nap getting in a full sleep
cycle so like 90 minutes seems to be the
best other alternative now there's not
many studies but using that kind of
method but I'm sure like like you said
if you now for three hours then you're
probably not doing something good later
aren't there are some cultures that kind
of build a short nap in in the middle of
the day yeah that's a siesta dog yeah I
thought yeah yeah how long is the siesta
typically do we know I don't know I'm
not culturally literate I might be
reflecting America outside of the south
oh you and me both where were you saying
Brandon you think it's I think it's at
me it's 60 to 90 minutes I think that's
pretty normal
I'm not entirely sure that you know this
yesterday is are the time in cultures
that spent in between the day when it's
you know really hot for three hours is
Slynt or spent fully sleeping but I'm
sure like 99 60 90 minutes is reasonable
is that the intended purpose is just
because it's so hot during the middle of
the day um I'm I'm gonna stretch myself
or stop myself and say I'm also not as
culturally literate as I should be
before I embarrass myself are you trying
to tell me that we are not the three
ideal people to discuss the cultural
phenomenon of the siesta I feel like I I
resent the implication if three people
are gonna discuss siestas and the finer
points of Spanish culture
feel like we might as well take a stab I
feel like my into that at least alright
so the concept of sleep debt what is
sleep debt and can it be repaid so sleep
debt is just the kind of accumulated
debt of sleep so you have to do sleep
for a number of days maybe you're you
know traveling or you're studying or
you're preparing the project or
something and it can be repaid but it
can't be repaid all at once
so generally miles they generally are
there are a few different studies but it
looks like it takes a few days and the
best way to kind of pay off your sleep
debt is to not set an alarm clock and
just sleep until you kind of naturally
wake up for a few days in a row
which sounds terrifying to me because
I'm like super structured but that seems
to be the best way to kind of normalize
your sleep debt back out so I think the
only way you can really do that is if
you're on vacation maybe or something
but I have also read that it's
recommended and I this kind of makes
sense to catch up on sleep during the
weekend to repair some of your Mii pay
some of your sleep debt you used the
phrase there
don't set an alarm and and just kind of
sleep naturally for a few days in a row
Gregg would take that literally is not
outside the realm of possibility that he
would sleep for a few days in a row he
has done some pretty wild things in
terms of staying up for frankly
implausible numbers of hours and days so
if there was ever a case study on
developing a sleep debt and then
correcting it the things I've seen you
do Greg are in print like I'm not
picking on you I am I'm in awe of what
you've pulled off in terms of sleep
cycles the longest I've ever slept in
one clip uninterrupted is about 18 hours
whole 18 hours is a long stretch of time
so basically you're like a bear like
super-strong and you have the ability to
sleep for long periods so on the topic
of bears we were actually talking about
this earlier we this is true you're
talking about bears like three hours ago
yes so really really cool study that I
saw maybe three or four months ago is so
when bears hibernate they produce a a
hormonal and metabolic milieu to help
what do you know I know nothing about
siestas and my French pronunciation is
dog [ __ ] in the Americanized way I don't
know the Americanized way whatever you
you got a blend of hormones and [ __ ] and
[Applause]
anyway so bears they're obviously Eric's
[ __ ] losing it over years talking
when someone's laughing in my presence
anyways so damn it so bears hibernate
obviously during that time they're not
incredibly active they're not eating all
that much but when spring rolls around
they need to be able to find food and
have the energy to copulate and so they
need to maintain as much muscle tissue
as possible so they produced a bunch of
hormones and have a bunch of other
proteins in their blood to help promote
maintenance of muscle tissue with
extreme decreases in activity and so
there was a study where they extracted
hibernating bear serum and treated
muscle fibers with it in vitro and it
caused like legitimately like steroid
like effects and so I think that's
pretty sick because one I want to know
who had the cojones to how was my
pronunciation on that one Eric that was
good hell yeah so they had the cojones
to
extract serum or while I guess blood
from hibernating bears which I want to
know who pulled the short straw for that
one and then to it makes me interested
I'd be very interested if it became like
one if it worked in vivo and two if it
became mass-produced because I feel like
that is the most alpha move that someone
could possibly pull if like untested
lifters were discussing their stacks
someone's like oh yeah like I pinned
some Trin
pop some D ball some someone else would
come up and be like dude I [ __ ] inject
serum collected from hibernating bears
get on my [ __ ] level I feel like that
would be the most alpha gurga genic that
someone could possibly take so anyway
that's that's really all I have to say
about bears it would be natural and
therefore quite healthy one would have
to assume so it came from nature here
here's a hard here's a hard turn Brandon
do you know anything about active Egan I
do not I well sorry to say that so this
word octo vegan a CTO ve G I n not
familiar so on the topic of injecting
serum from animals into oneself so
active vegan is commonly like the street
name for it is calf's blood and much
like bears need to preserve muscle
during hibernation calves obviously need
to grow a tremendous amount very quickly
to become big cows I think that's the
technical term and so what they do is
they take blood from calves spin it down
remove the red blood cells and
apparently it's very rich in hormones
and growth factors and apparently if
like American athletes are doing
offseason training in Europe it is
probably so they can get act o vegan
injections because it's legal and in
some places in Europe but
in the US and apparently it's one of
those things with very little research
on it but that elite athletes swear by
but don't swear by to publicly because
even though it's not technically
outlawed by anti-doping authorities
there's like a stipulation in wadis code
where it's basically like you know we
listed the things that are explicitly
illegal and but we reserve the right to
say that something is against the rules
if it is a like patently clear attempt
to gain some sort of advantage by
injecting something into your body like
it's just a very broad catch-all so
there it's kind of dubious legality
under the water code but I think I also
think that's super interesting because
you know it's not something that people
are making in a lab it's just [ __ ]
get some blood from calves spin it down
and inject it into humans and hope for
the best and apparently it's fairly
widespread so we're keeping an eye out
for bear act extract and baby calf
extract it sounds like correct
I have either one of my friends I did my
PhD with is actually working at USANA
now it's after from that one by I'm been
asking about it that would be
interesting I'd love to talk to somebody
from water.you sada all right Brandon
we've got a final question here about
sleep so you did this deep dive in the
literature wrote a really long
comprehensive article about sleep in the
process of doing your lit review and
writing the article have you changed
anything about the way you approach
sleep or your current sleep habits yeah
so that was one of the perks is that two
major things changed one I basically
slept an extra probably hour and a half
so I'm like at a solid eight hours a
night
and - my wife loves naps and I used to
give her a hard time about it and I'd no
longer do that so she was like she was
right and you were
yeah yeah uh-huh I definitely had to
definitely very we do have a question
that we like to ask a lot of our guests
especially who are more on the sciency
side of things do are there any training
or nutrition practices that you
personally believe very strongly in that
either there's no research to support or
possibly even that there is research
against that just based on your own
experiences or experiences with clients
you still think is good stuff oh man all
right I will give you a kind of like a
brief summary so I think there are a lot
of things you can get from video
basically form stuff not the big three
but just like dumbbell curls and random
accessories that people do that can make
a pretty big difference in kind of
activation that probably haven't been
shown yet or maybe they have there's
like one study so like lat pull-downs
right a lot of people do the overhand
grip and just I have most of my athletes
switch to a neutral grip and it you know
I don't know that there's any evidence
that that's like better forever trophy
or whatnot but most of them or back that
I go oh my gosh that's so much better so
yeah there's one for you but yeah I have
a couple of them you know I agree with
you on that one you know I've got like a
slight imbalance between my lats and
that kind of forced me to start doing my
lat pull-downs unilaterally one arm at a
time and just in switching over to that
my grip naturally became more neutral
with a single handle and I'm I'm
inclined to agree with your clients and
with you in the sense that that neutral
grip lat pulldown is is wild man I
I recommend that all the time have you
guys played around with Ring pull-ups
very much no I have not no so I I think
you guys may enjoy that or
so the the drawback with rings is that
they swing obviously which can be
annoying one of the few like late-night
infomercial fitness products that I've
tried that is actually good is there was
this thing they advertise like maybe ten
years ago called the perfect pull-up and
it was the same general type of thing
but instead of a ring it was just you
know like a flat handle the same way
that like a cable crossover handle would
be but it would rotate or it allowed you
to rotate as you did pull-ups and the
the thing is like like a underhand grip
is a very natural position to be in at
the top of a pull-up and an overhand
grip is a very natural position to be in
at the bottom of a pull-up and I agree
that if you just have a fixed bar
neutral grip is great but a lot of
people either prefer neutral grip or the
ability to like change from pronation to
supination throughout a rep and and
rings rings are a really good option if
a gym has rings but not a place to do
neutral grip pull-ups back pocket for
later you know I'll have to look into I
think my gym does have a ring set up but
I've never wandered over there it's
worth playing with it feels a little bit
too functional for me once one of those
rings involved you know I like my hammer
strength stuff I like to go straight
1980's bodybuilding if I can that's fair
well Brandon thanks so much for making
time for us I know you're busy guy you
got a lot of stuff going on and we
really appreciate your time it's been
really great talking to you about all
these different aspects of Exercise
Science that you've got expertise in
before we let you go if people want to
stay in touch with you if people want to
see what you're up to how can they get
in touch with you yeah for sure so I do
I actually found a home for my article
and that's gonna be at JPS Fitness
website
but apart apart from that you can
contact me through the straight guys
where I do my coaching
I have some semblance of like a website
fitness and physiology comm and then
Facebook and Instagram I'm trying to do
more Instagram stuff but you know
keeping up with everything is kind of
hard so and what's your Instagram handle
so it's B Rob underscore 21 very nice so
listeners stay in touch with Brandon
he's always doing cool things always
putting out good information
Brandon once again we want to thank you
for your time and we want to wish you
good luck in your final competition in a
few weeks all right well thank you guys
for having me and keep doing the good
work that you do
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science com2 check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you